das schreckensszenario im lsc in genf
werden schwarze löcher produziert die
unseren gesamten planeten vernichten
so dachten kritiker 2008 jetzt wird der
lfc der large hadron collider der
stärkste teilchenbeschleuniger der welt
wieder angeschaltet mit fast doppelter
energie klicks und science fiction der
lfc der large hadron collider ist der
größte teilchenbeschleuniger der welt in
der maschine werden protonen und blei
kerne mit 99 9 prozent der
lichtgeschwindigkeit aufeinander
geschossen werden sie ist ein ring mit
einer länge von 27 kilometern
tief unten in der erde und 11.000 mal in
der sekunde schießen die protonen durch
den ring um dann aufeinander zu treffen
während mit raumschiffen teleskopen
satelliten und radioteleskopen in die
unendlichen weiten des universums
geschaut wird wird mit dem lg in der in
die welt der elementarteilchen
eingetaucht und so immer neue teilchen
entdeckt 2012 wurde im lg das
gottesteilchen das higgs boson entdeckt
damit war ein wichtiges teilchen des
standardmodells der
elementarteilchenphysik gefunden das
schon 1964 vorhergesagt wurde
das higgs teilchen ist ein teilchen das
durch die anregung des feldes entsteht
nur wenige sekundenbruchteile existiert
es war vorhergesagt worden weil die
elementarteilchen also zb elektroden
sich nicht immer gleich verhalten haben
nur dass hitzfeld konnte das seltsame
verhalten von elementarteilchen erklärt
2012 wurde es dann endlich im netz
gefunden
doch es gibt noch viel mehr ungeklärte
fragen wie wird die gravitation in der
teilchenphysik erklärt wo ist die
antimaterie was und wo sind die unmengen
an dunkler materie verdammt noch mal
diese im ganzen universum geben muss
fragen auf die es keine antworten gibt
und auch keine theorien jedenfalls nicht
eine einzige wie beim higgs-teilchen da
war alles sonnenklar
obwohl stoppt die supersymmetrie kurz
susi am anfang des universums kurz nach
dem urknall könnte es sie gegeben haben
denn was sich bei den crash versuchen im
exil immer mehr herauskristallisiert
umso höher die energie desto mehr nähern
sich die drei grundkräfte des
standardmodells der em
teilchen die elektromagnetische kraft
die schwache und die starke kernkraft
aneinander an
dann hätte es kurz nach dem urknall nur
ein einzige kraft gegeben
diese kraft kann aber nur existiert
haben
wenn es damals zu jedem teilchen ein
spiegelbild gegeben hätte heute gebe es
diese spiegelwelt diese supersymmetrie
nicht mehr aber ein sehr leichtes super
teilchen das neutral lino das könnte es
noch gegen gefunden werden diese
teilchen in den detektoren des alexy in
denen die teilchen die protonen oder
auch die drei kerne aufeinandertreffen
600 millionen tracks passieren dort pro
sekunde
und nur weil aufwändige software alle
unwichtigen ereignisse herausfiltert
sind die außergewöhnlichen ergebnisse
überhaupt in der datenflut zu finden
es wird also eine reise ins unbekannte
und es kann auch eine reise ins
nirgendwo werden dennoch gibt es kaum
anhaltspunkte für die supersymmetrie die
gravitation in der teilchenphysik oder
auch bei der dunkle materie oder der
antimaterie da stochern die forscher
noch weitestgehend im dunkeln drum
es wird also spannend anhaltspunkte für
die dunkle materie wurden allerdings
schon gefunden hier geht es zum video
hier die zehn grössten rätsel unseres
universums und 1 dieser rätsel ist eben
die dunkle materie zum blog und zur app
wie immer geht es da mit täglichen
vision wissenschafts news und was meint
ihr welches rätsel könnte noch im exil
gelebt werden schreibt es in die
kommentare
bis dann bleibt dran